blacks were there from the very
beginning so what you had was a
thickening of people's okay blacks were
always here immigrants were always here
and it just sort of sort of thickened
but you never had a real push in and as
you can see in this area there were now
the Jews lived south of Center Avenue
that was the heavily Jewish part but the
Goldblum's were here and there other
Jewish families you know a lot of
overlap and blacks lived over the
Italians lived down down that way the
Italians and the Greeks and the Syrians
down there but there were Jews who lived
in there and blacks who lived in there
as well there was a lot of lot of
overlapping and it was it was a
remarkable neighborhood in terms of you
know one of the things that people think
by reading the history of cities like
Chicago or Washington there's awful very
early race riots you know before the
king assassination
well Pittsburgh didn't have those and
when you look at the history of American
cities I think as you look in most
places they didn't have that so we have
this sense of you know people will never
be able to get along they'll always be
fighting tooth and nail but this place
shows no not necessarily things can be
different
but we focus on it's like the dog that
barks you know if it's quiet and nothing
happens
historians don't look at it or
newspapers don't look at it or whatever
if there is a riot of outbreak oh that
gets the attention and if you only look
at those then you generalize from those
and that's another thing that the
pittsburgh story will tell that this was
a neighborhood where people did get
along did get along together by getting
out and really seeing life and paying
attention to it August realized life is
complex and that's what makes this place
so interesting because they're not just
simplistic agitprop sort of things where
you know the answer you know the good
guys you know the bad guys they're all
runners on this side the others on that
side
people have conflicting feelings and he
was really able to to capture that
because he not only did he observe but
he thought about what he had observed
and he was very honest
and when you are you get down to the
human element and within black America
there is variety they're not all just
one thing or the other there are
different opinions and he captures that
and shows that in his plays in our youth
there are all sorts of arguments in
August place where people are going back
and forth on some topic because he
realized that you know we're not simple
people simple minds or complex just like
anybody else and that's really part of
of why he's such a compelling playwright
our encore presentation of some of the
stops along the c-span city's tour from
this past year continues as we take you
to Concord Massachusetts here we are in
Concord Massachusetts on the Lexington
Road which is also known as the Battle
Road it's where the Redcoats marched
into the North Bridge on April the 19th
of 1775 starting the American Revolution
this house was standing here then
eventually much much later than that it
becomes the home of amos bronson alcott
and his family now one of the daughters
louisa may alcott
in this house writes a book that really
changes a lot of the way people think
about children the way they think about
young women the way they think about
Madore women it was a very progressive
book for its day and frankly in many
ways today it still remains this because
it's just a simple true to life story of
for young women and their parents mr.
Olcott was an educator primarily in the
early days mrs. Alcott was a very
progressive thinker who was deeply in
love with mr. Alcott they were in Boston
when mr. Alcott met Ralph Waldo Emerson
and they struck up quite a deep
friendship Emerson was well ensconced in
Concord in fact he thought Bronson
Alcott belonged here he felt that this
this town had something special to offer
you had the political revolution in 1775
and you sort of had a literary
revolution in the 1800s but Mr Emerson
really wanted Bronson Alcott to move
here well now here in mr. Alcott study I
wanted to focus for a moment on what's
above the fireplace this was really an
expression of mr. Alcott life-long
belief the hills are reared the seas are
scooped in vain if learnings alter
vanish from the plane
and of course it's a very elaborate way
of saying never stop learning you really
are never too young to start and you're
never too old to keep going and that was
very very important mr. Olcott dedicated
most of his life to education in the
early years he was educating the young
and his educational ideas were extremely
unusual for the day it was an era when
most teachers were concerned primarily
with order in the classroom they would
use the rod some of the expressions
which we find a little funny today must
not have been funny to the children
because one of them was if a boys not
bad now he's about to be just go ahead
and strike if you spare the rod you
spoil the child
and mr. Olcott thought of the rod more
like a staff to guide you know like a
walking stick I think he would not
strike the students he allowed questions
in the classroom which again was frowned
upon by most teachers because that would
promote rudeness the teacher knows what
you have to know so why are you
encouraging these questions so he had a
lot of difficulty with people getting
nervous about these unusual techniques
they hadn't heard of and yet the
children were learning more and really
loved mr. Olcott so it was it was really
the right thing he was just about a
hundred years ahead of his time
now his lifelong dream had really been
to teach adults as well and he did find
that he could finally do that in this
room in 1879 so over here we have one of
the cofounders of the school of
philosophy that's what Brunson all cut
chose to call his adult learning
opportunity that started in this room in
1879 mr. Emerson once said of Bronson
Alcott that mr. Alcott is the foremost
genius of our day these two gentlemen
were closest of friends they walked
together just about on a daily basis and
they really supported each other and
everything so it is not a surprise that
he helped to co-found this Concord
school of philosophy as mr. Alcott
called it the first year as I say it
began in this room but it soon was
overflowing these walls people even
opened the windows and stood outside
so they could hear and one of the
attendees donated $500 which was a
princely sum in those days and asked
that a small lecture hall be built and
that is the building up on the hill many
people think it was the barn but it was
never a barn it was always meant to be a
very rustic looking structure but a
lecture hall when it comes to finances
the Alcott's had a saying that they had
the Olcott sinking fund it seemed that
their finances just got worse and worse
and worse
mr. Olcott was not always paid very well
for what he was doing it wasn't that he
wasn't working hard it was that he was a
little too innovative and sometimes
people just didn't appreciate enough
what he was doing one time very poignant
Lee he said Oh promises were not always
kept my overcoat was stolen I had to buy
a shawl but I've opened up the way I'll
do better another time he was always
trying hard but not necessarily doing
well financially but sometimes it meant
that all of the women in the household
were pitching in in a way that in that
era was not considered very ladylike it
was supposed to be the man doing all the
the earning and the woman just tidying
up the house and cooking and cleaning
and raising the children they were
really a little bit unusual financially
that way so they were definitely
struggling a lot of the time well here
we are in the all cuts dining room and
of course they took meals here mrs.
alcot English coalport China was
sometimes the service used this was
their best China and the initial M is
for her maiden name Mae which is
interesting because we have Louisa Mae
and Abigail Mae Mae was not a made-up
name that was her maiden name spelled ma
Y and this is English coalport China
mrs. alcot had a funny expression one
time they were struggling financially a
lot of the time and so once she said
will always be a respectable family
because we have our fine china of course
she was teasing she wasn't really that
serious about it but she was very
pleased to have this and
than in her family and then over in this
direction we have some wonderful
portraits this one is particularly
interesting of Louisa May all cut now
she looks less well in this portrait
then she did a few years earlier because
she's 38 years old here and she had been
in the Civil War as a Union Army nurse
contracted typhus and pneumonia was
treated with heavy doses of calomel
which is mercury and today we know that
mercury is not good to ingest but back
then it was a medication they thought
that the disease was leaving you as you
were also losing your teeth and your
hair and everything else so she managed
to recover from all of this much to the
amazement of many people because others
who were as sick as she was did not
recover
now George Healey who was a very famous
portrait artist at that time learned
that the famous miss Alcott was in Italy
at the same time he was and little women
had become an international hit someone
has recently said to me that louisa may
alcott
in that day was more famous than JK
rowling probably because there wasn't as
much competition with sports figures and
movie stars and such but she was a huge
international sensation and this George
Healey asked miss Alcott if he could
paint her and I say today we're very
proud that we have this George Healey
painting in our dining room the only
other dining room in America that I know
of with a George Healey in it is the
White House where there is a wonderful
portrait of Abraham Lincoln done by
George Healy he was in that day the big
painter who would be summoned to paint
presidents so it was quite an honor that
she was painted by mr. Healey however
she was very disappointed she said I
look like a smoky relic from the Boston
fire there had been a fire in 1872 when
it was a terrible disaster in Boston and
she just thought that she looked like
she had stepped right out of that fire
she said we should hang at
behind a door and then we have an
interesting likeness of Elizabeth Alcott
she is the actual model for Beth in
Little Women and she's the only one
whose name does not change in the Little
Women account this is the only likeness
that we have of her and she's the one
who died just before they moved into
this house they spent a whole year
fixing this house up and she came many
times she saw the work they were doing
they were excited about this was going
to be the finest home for them this is
the place they lived the longest and yet
she sort of knew because she was so ill
that perhaps she would not be living
here she even said she thought Sleepy
Hollow might be her new home and indeed
that is what happened if you look at
this archway that leads into the parlor
the girls even as young women we're
still putting on plays as they had done
all through their early years and they
hung a curtain between these two rooms
so that the dining room portion with the
table moved out of the way could become
their stage and they had many wonderful
scene sets and scenery and costumes they
really worked hard on these and then the
audience would sit here and in Little
Women toward the beginning of the book
the girls are going to put on a play as
a Christmas present it's going to call
Roderigo or the bandits bride that is
really a play that Louisa did right she
did perform in it she played the role of
Roderigo they performed it right in that
dining room and at one point in Little
Women it describes the audience sitting
on a sort of a cot that collapses during
the play and another times the scenery
collapsed these things really happened
to them all the time and it was always
Louisa like Jo in the book saying like
nothing's wrong keep going keep going so
she was really one who loved the
dramatic impulse and I think that that
shows in her writing today that her
early experience doing these these plays
these dramas with her sisters helped to
inform her writing style
Louisa loved making up stories she often
made them up just out loud when they
walked along
taking a walk in the in the area around
Walden Pond with Henry David Thoreau but
she also would record a lot of these
things and do a lot of writing as well
so I would say she was probably writing
almost every day she loved it and it was
an a release for her as well as an
outlet she didn't have a tremendous
amount of success at first but she had
some success almost from the beginning
in the sense that she had short stories
and poems published early on and I think
that was enough to keep her going now at
one juncture when she was teaching
school in Boston and she boarded with
James fields famous publisher and his
wife Annie she showed mr. fields some of
her writing and was very hopeful that
this you know she's living in that
household and maybe he'll take an
interest he told her stick to your
teaching miss Alcott you can't write
that really just made her more
determined she kept going much much
later after Little Women had been
published she paid mr. field back alone
that he had very kindly given her to
help with her establishment of her first
little school and she said with all due
respect I think I shall stick to my
writing as it pays rather better than my
teaching so she really did sort of come
full circle with it and became obviously
a big financial success eventually
well thou coming up to the second floor
we have the parents bedroom may all
caught the youngest sister who was Amy
in the book
bedroom and then in this room it is the
most popular the most important to most
people is where Louisa May Alcott wrote
Little Women this is her bedchamber
originally she shared it with her sister
Anna who was called Meg in the story and
of course you know that Louisa was Jo
and this is where at a little half moon
desk built for Louisa by her father she
sat and penned Little Women
now one thing that I think is very
important to note is that in that era it
was commonly thought that brain works
such as writing would ruin a woman's
health doctors had even written articles
that they had now proven this and even
if you weren't concerned medically
people just thought it wasn't seemly for
a woman to write seriously to write for
publication it was fine to write letters
but you know this was something you
should reserve for the men the fact that
Louise's family supported her in this
way was really quite amazing and the
building of this desk was more than just
a convenience it was really a wonderful
support psychologically for Louisa May
Alcott Louise's mother was equally
supportive she made her a scribbling
suit and a cap that she could pull down
when she needed to concentrate kind of
closed herself off from the world mrs.
Alcott also gave Louisa a pen and wrote
a little note with the pen saying may
this pen your muse inspire when wrapped
in pure poetic fire so she had wonderful
support from her family now Little Women
was a simple story - Louisa it was
really the family story she didn't
really think much would come of it when
she first sent it off to the publishers
but she made note in her journal that
they had really lived most of it and if
it would succeed that would be the
reason well her
sure looked at it and didn't think that
much of it either but he gave it to his
niece who loved it who loved it more
than anything she had ever written so
the publisher decided well we're gonna
go with this and conservatively start
off with a very small number but that
first edition it was about 2,500 books
sold out very fast and so then of course
more copies were printed and people then
as now might have been a little
surprised such a simple story but it was
way ahead of its time in many ways and
yet it walked a fine line between
leading people into more progressive
thought such as the idea that a woman
could be independent that a woman could
have ideas of her own that she could
have a temper and not be considered the
villain of the piece all of these human
qualities that women were often sort of
told to suppress came out in the person
of Joel March and had been of course in
the person of Louisa May all cut all
along and the family was not perfect at
all they all had flaws they sort of
struggled in many ways and yet they
supported each other they loved each
other they they went on they never felt
sorry for themselves and sat around and
said well I guess I'm such an heir do
well I can't do anything they kept going
so this is a very inspiring role model
for people who read this book especially
young women for whom it was really
intended Little Women succeeded beyond
Louise's wildest imaginings it made her
really a superstar of the day now this
of course changed everything partially
because her very honest publishers name
was Thomas miles of Roberts brothers
publisher they later become Little Brown
Thomas advised Louisa to keep the
copyright which was wonderful advice
because that meant that she could really
make money on this book and she became
quite wealthy by the standards of the
day I you know you probably would think
of her almost like a millionaire today
now that of course made the family very
comfortable and allowed all their debts
to be repaved they could then feel at
ease
in that regard and she Louisa was so
generous she was always doing kindnesses
for others if someone needed something
and she could do it she often would be
helping others in much the same way they
had been helped when she was young
particularly by Ralph Waldo Emerson
their close family friend he was always
slipping a $10 bill under a tablecloth
or something like that and trying to
make sure that they didn't see so that
they would just find it later and not be
able to say wait a minute you put that
there he was always trying to help them
well Louisa took note of that and did
the same sort of thing so she made a
difference in everyone's life who was
anywhere near her you know it's
interesting the literary history of
Concord is so multifaceted and depending
upon what's interest you could easily
just bypass an author's home because you
can read the books but there's something
about this particular book and this
particular house that is unique in the
sense that as far as I know it is the
only piece of literature that not only
has maintained its its importance to so
many people it's never been out of print
widely translated well over 50
translations very beloved by people of
all cultures and it was written and set
in a house that is now open to the
public when people walk through this
house they often will say to me this is
like walking through the book someone
once said well it's as if you could
really go to Hogwarts after you read
Harry Potter but Hogwarts is not a real
place and this is
[Applause]
our encore presentation of some of the
stops along the c-span city's tour from
this past year continues as we take you
to Concord Massachusetts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's interesting that very often readers
of Walled and when they first come to
the pond are a little puzzled maybe a
little disappointed because when you
read Walden
you really are expecting to be to be
just amazed at the landscape and the
fact that that Thoreau could could be
everyday just staggered by a landscape
as humble as this that takes a little
getting used to and so it was it was
just a little pond and now it's a it's
an icon of American literary history
Henry David Thoreau first came out here
as a little boy and he he remembered
that excursion long after but he came
here with his family actually to gather
sand for his father's sand paper
manufacturing enterprise and but he came
here to live it was actually on July 4th
1845 locally that he came to live and
then was out here for for two years
after that and his friend Ralph Waldo
Emerson had not long before bought the
property we're standing on now as a
woodlot basically the the the soil
around walden isn't good for much except
growing trees and he asked emerson if he
could if he could put up a structure
here and stay here for a while and
memmer said Emerson said surely his
principle purpose was to find a sort of
writers studio for himself it was
something he'd been thinking about for
several years that that and the specific
project he had in mind was a book in in
memoriam to his brother John who had
died in 1841
the book is about a trip that he took
with John in 1839 they were both very
young but they took a trip by boat up to
New Hampshire and that's the loosely the
the thread that runs through a week on
the Concord and Merrimack which is the
the book that he wrote here well he was
here it's sort of easy to imagine that
Thoreau was was all alone and if you
read the book you would think he's like
halfway up the slopes of mount cotopaxi
or something that he was off at the you
know at the end of the world somewhere
but he's not he's connected to town it's
only a little over a mile away
especially if you take the railroad cut
there you're in town and in no time and
he had lots and lots of visitors while
he was out here so it's it's not that he
was he was isolated but he had plenty of
the solitude that he wanted as a thinker
and a writer the house he built what he
tells us in the first chapter of Walden
was 10 by 15 feet which is a fairly
substantial space it's about the size of
most craftsmen's workshops and in that
period you can get a lot done in 10 by
15 feet and it was sufficient for for
Thoreau he not immediately but he soon
planted a field of beans and tried to
get by in part on on them but the you
know for the the rest of his living it
was supplies that he would get from from
town rice and things like that Thoreau
came to Walden already with a set of
ideas about what the about what wildness
is not the wilderness but wildness
that's what interested him the part of
the exercise in coming to Walden
to remove himself from from culture you
know that sounds sort of drastic but you
you do catch artists at it every now and
again go guys a good a good example he
went to Tahiti and part of the reason he
went there was to put all of Europe
behind him and this is something that
that Emerson suggested and in a number
of places but that he thought it was
important for Americans to to put that
behind them a one good way to do it is
to come out and live by yourself in a in
a in a house with no neighbors at that
point there historically there had been
other people living out here but they
were for the most part gone when Thoreau
was out here not long after Thoreau came
to Walden that the I'd the idea of the
book Walden started to occur to him and
if you look at his journal from from
that period there are passages clipped
from it that that were worked into some
of the early drafts and the and the
lectures that he gave on the subject
right in the beginning of Walden the
book he says that it was curiosity on
the parts of the part of his neighbors
they wanted to know if he was lonely if
he fee you know why aren't you afraid
out there and so on and so he he started
answering those questions that Lyceum
lectures and it kind of grew from there
but of course he changed you know it was
not just a narrative of my experience
that book is subtitled life in the woods
and Thoreau had the publisher get rid of
that subtitle eventually it really
wasn't just a narrative of what it's
like to live out in the woods it's
obviously a more complicated book than
that there was Walden the experience
which was just two years but Walden the
book was a much longer project it wasn't
published until 1854 it actually went
through seven different drafts so in the
interim Thoreau took up a new
methodology of observation around 18 51
52 he took up a new way of observing the
world and a lot of that is reflected in
the final draft of Walden so it's it it
takes a little takes some exercise an
intellectual exercise to to pick apart
those threads and figure out what it is
that he's up to while he's actually out
here Walden was more successful than a
week on the Concord and Merrimack in
fact the deal Thoreau had made with his
publisher for a week which was the book
he came to Walden to write was that if
it didn't sell Thoreau would pay for the
publication and so he ended up being
responsible for for the publication he
and and but Walden sold better than that
it only went through one addition during
Thoreau's lifetime but it did sell much
better than a week one of the things
that I was careful to point out in in
the text of Walden is that he doesn't
really mean for anybody to imitate his
his experiment and he talks about it as
an experiment rather I think he wanted
his readers to first have the sort of
odd response to to the remarkable fact
of man in nature as the way Thoreau put
it if if readers take that away that was
good enough for him if they thought
about the relationship between what they
do to get a living and what their life
consists of then I think he would have
counted that as success
you're watching book TV on c-span -
television for serious readers here's
our primetime lineup at 7:30 p.m.
Eastern right Bart senior editor at
large Joel Pollak reports on the 2016
presidential election then at 8:15
American University law professor Angela
Jay Davis explores the u.s. criminal
justice system's impact on
african-american men on book TVs
afterwards at 10 p.m.
former Breitbart editor milo gianopolous
offers his thoughts on the limits of
free speech at 11:00 p.m.
journalist David Barron recalls the
total solar eclipse of 1878 and at 11:45
from last month's annual libertarian
conference Freedom Fest James O'Keefe
founder and president of project Veritas
offers his thoughts on the media that
all happens tonight on c-span 2's book
TV and now Joel Pollak on the 2016
presidential election
Breitbart news senior editor at large
Joel Pollak take us back to August 2015
and how you felt about the 2016 election
well I was not optimistic about Trump's
chances or really any Republicans
chances against Hillary Clinton
my co-author Larry Schweikart felt quite
differently and he predicted back in
August 2015
that Trump would not only win the
Republican nomination but would go on to
win the presidency and he did that on
the basis of data that he was looking at
particularly the large number of
Democrats in key counties and places
like Northeastern Ohio who are switching
their party registration from Democratic
to Republican and one of the reasons
they were doing that was they had
watched the first couple of presidential
debates and they realized that Trump was
speaking about issues that many of these
Rust Belt Democratic voters cared about
trade and immigration Bernie Sanders was
talking about those issues also which is
one of the reasons he did so well in the
Democratic Party's primary but for many
of the voters in the Rust Belt and in
other swing counties across America
Trump was where the action was and so my
co-author said this is where it's going
to be on election day more than a year
from now I was much more skeptical
although I did see that something was
happening I think you can trace the
dates that Trump seized control of the
election to July 10th 2015 that was
about three and a half weeks after he
launched his campaign and for that first
three and a half weeks he was kind of
bumping along the bottom in the polls
but on July 10th he met with the
families of the remembrance project
these are people who've lost loved ones
to crimes by illegal aliens whether
drunk driving or murder and Trump showed
empathy for those families
Breitbart covered it The Associated
Press covered it there's a great
photograph by Jay hong of trump standing
with his arms folded listening to these
families and within nine days he had
shot from number six in the polls
straight to number one and he almost
never relinquished that lead it was
showing conservative voters first of all
that he was going to take up an issue
that was important to them but also
showing voters in general that he sided
with families and with people who had
been denied protection from the
government that they had a right to
expect or that they had been promised
they would receive and so I think that
emotionally and in terms of the polls is
where he took over the election but I
still thought Hillary Clinton had
history on her side first female nominee
I thought that was going to be very hard
for anybody to beat but within a few
months I came around to the view that
Trump had a real chance because of the
way he took on the media in a way that
no other Republican candidate did how
embedded with the campaign were you not
very at the beginning I was covering
West Coast campaign events for all of
the campaigns Trump Bernie Hillary we
tried to get Breitbart people to Ted
Cruz events all kinds of things like
that so in the primary stage I was
mostly focused on the west coast and I
would travel to events when they
happened there but I joined the campaign
press corps the traveling press for
around Donald Trump's campaign for the
last stretch of the campaign once the
general election was already well
underway into the debates and so forth
and covered that homestretch now I have
to say even then I didn't expect him to
win and when I started thinking about
the idea for this book my initial title
was going to be something like in the
fall of Trump Tower or something like
that I just really just did not see that
he would have a great chance of winning
I put his chances at about 20 or 30
percent and I viewed it almost as this
tragic exercise this larger-than-life
American figure this picture of
individualism and achievement that
almost had literary residence in
American culture not just through TVs
apprentice but through his own books and
his cultural impact and yet falling
short at the end that's kind of how I
saw things happening and over the course
of the next few weeks and towards
Election Day there were events and
things that I experienced that led me to
believe his chances were a little
stronger than that but it was as much a
surprise to me on election night when he
won as it was to Frank Luntz who said at
6:00 in the evening that Hillary Clinton
was going to be the next president in
the United States now my co-author Larry
had a completely different perspective
he had sources of data that were
proprietary he had sources in various
counties that were telling him what was
going on he was much more confident that
Trump was going to win and he predicted
very closely the electoral votes by
which Trump would win so he had his
fingers really on the data and he was
confident in that data and I was steeped
in the media looking at what Trump was
saying looking what people were saying
about Trump and to
me and I never wrote him off never
thought he didn't belong at the top of
the ticket I never thought he didn't
have a chance but it was a surprise when
he finally pulled it off but there were
interesting things about his rapport
with his voters that were early signs of
their devotion to him that they would
march over broken glass barefoot to the
polls to vote for Donald Trump on
election day was it you or your
co-author who went to see the grave of
rabbi Schneerson haha that was me yeah
that was me I I went there Jared Kushner
and Ivanka Trump had gone a few days
before and I had actually never been
before that visit of all who was okay so
Rabbi Menachem Mendel Schneerson was the
seventh labarbera Rebbe
he passed away just over 20 years ago
but in his lifetime he rescued you could
say post-war Judaism and gave it a
religious direction that many people
thought it would never have again after
the Holocaust even with the
establishment of the State of Israel
Israel's leaders at the time assumed
that religious judaism was fading and if
it existed it existed in small insular
pockets and he reversed that he promoted
Jewish ideas Jewish values Jewish
practices as good in and of themselves
not just as a tradition you wanted to
preserve but as positive forces for
change in the world that weren't just
restricted to Jews that the values that
Judaism promotes would be helpful to
humanity as a whole and he inspired
thousands of people to become
missionaries in effect to other Jewish
communities all around the world in the
course of that project he became very
widely respected not just in New York
where he lived but throughout the
country for his advice the advice
political leaders he had deep political
insights not just into American politics
but into Israeli politics and global
affairs and politicians would come to
seek his advice there are pictures of
him talking to Robert Kennedy and
correspondence with Ronald Reagan and
things like that bipartisan his impact
was on both parties leaders of both
parties who sought his advice
and I just decided to check it out on
Election Day Jared and Ivanka probably
for the same reason you know I made no
secret of the fact that I was Trump
supporter I read for a conservative
website and I went and it was quite an
interesting experience and it was just
lull in the day and I took that time
because usually when people are voting
is not much news so I took this couple
of hours and I talked about it a little
bit in the book but the tradition is to
write a note to leave at the grave site
of the Rebbe there are thousands and
thousands of notes at this grave site
the the jockey who won the Triple Crown
on American Pharoah left a note and he
went on to win the Triple Crown the next
day but anyway I left my note on the
sort of side of the grave area and I
intended to fold it up and put it on the
grave and then this his breeze came
through and sort of lifted it up and it
landed on the grave site which which to
me was kind of interesting anyway I got
an uber back into town to get ready for
the victory party and this uber got lost
in Queens and so I was stuck in Queens
for an hour which made me very nervous
about missing deadlines and so forth but
it was amazing to see the world Donald
Trump came from the and ring through
these streets and Queens that this is
who he is he's a guy who grew up in
Queens and made it in Manhattan and has
now achieved the ultimate ambition that
he or his family would have would have
imagined and so that was a very
interesting way to spend the afternoon
on Election Day of course when I got to
the Trump victory party that night it
felt like a funeral it was 7:30 at night
people looked a little bit dejected it
was a small issue at the Hilton or at
Trump Tower this was at the Hilton this
is that the media access to the victory
party and you know the donors were
gathering there and most of the people
you know the really inner circle was at
Trump Tower for a while but the Hilton
party felt very very diminished very sad
kind of quiet I talked to my Breitbart
colleagues there and they all had
explanations for why Trump was going to
lose people felt this wasn't looking
good the exit polls were terrible and so
forth and then we were looking at the
screen there was this map of Florida and
the Panhandle counties hadn't come
through yet now I just been there with
the Trump campaign in Pensacola and my
wife actually did her Navy training in
Pensacola so I know the area somewhat
well and that is deep deep red country
it's very very Republican in fact so
Republican that when I asked a woman at
this rally in Pensacola the same
question I asked people everywhere which
is why are you here what drew you to
Donald Trump I said to her why are you
here she said because I'm not an idiot I
said that was her that was her answer
that's how automatic the vote was in
those counties so I said well if they
haven't counted those counties yet how
do we know which way Florida is gonna go
and sure enough a short while later
those County started to come in the
state flipped into the Trump column and
suddenly everybody felt Trump was gonna
win
now I didn't think he was automatically
going to win because he was winning
Florida in fact I counted on him winning
Florida in my pre-election calculations
I knew that his strategy had to be to
pick off a blue state he was not going
to win by using the tried and tested and
often failed Republican strategy of just
winning the conservative states and
competing in the swing states there
about 12 swing states I knew that he was
going to have to steal at least one
state from the blue column and this has
been a Republican idea for quite a while
Sarah Palin wanted to do it in 2008 and
a campaign held her back from
campaigning in Michigan Mitt Romney and
Paul Ryan tried to swing Wisconsin this
has been an idea out there but Trump
really wanted to do it and the day
before the election I actually ran into
Frank Luntz I tell this story in the
book I ran into him on the outskirts of
a rally in North Carolina and I said to
him Frank can Trump win and he said yeah
he can win if he wins Nevada New
Hampshire Ohio in Florida Ohio I felt he
was gonna win Florida I thought his
chances were 50/50 New Hampshire I
thought also 5050 but Nevada I thought
Trump was going to lose because the
early vote for Democrats had already
come in and it was massive and I said
him well can he lose Nevada and win one
of the blue states and he looked at me
like I had fallen off the moon and he
said which one and he just couldn't
imagine of course the next day he
1/3 of those blue states he wanted
Pennsylvania Michigan and Wisconsin
Wisconsin was really the one that
clinched it and it was the one that know
pollsters saw Larry Schweikart my
co-author who was running his own
election models said that his team
predicted Trump's victory everywhere
except Wisconsin so everywhere it
happened they were right but they did
not think Wisconsin was gonna come into
the red column and it did and once
Wisconsin lit up then I said okay now
you can pop the champagne corks this is
over but of course it took three or four
more hours for the network's to call it
and standing there in the media gallery
you know around me was the press corps
and people look to kind of crestfallen
but they they did their jobs and and we
were sort of left at the end the
Breitbart crew watching all of this and
realizing suddenly that Donald Trump
would be the next president of United
States and we've covered this and in a
sense covered the conservative arguments
as well as some of the liberal ones
against Trump but we'd been in the
middle of a fight because Breitbart had
been one of the more supportive
conservative outlets of Trump's
candidacy and suddenly the reality of
what had happened hit us and it was just
this remarkable moment in history so it
was a real privilege to be there and I
write about that and I write about a lot
of that drama in the last few weeks in
the book did the party start to fill up
once Florida came in and once some of
these other states oh yes oh yes yes
there were many people who started
streaming in at about 9:30 that night
and it was pandemonium for a long time
we were in the media gallery looking
down on the floor but it was kind of
like a mosh pit from about midnight to
3:00 in the morning before finally the
AP called the race and there was some
booing when John Podesta came out and
said they're going to still count some
more votes and postpone this to the next
day or whatever and people started
booing and then one network at coal
Pennsylvania so anyway lots of drama but
I think what's really interesting to
people is not so much the election night
dramatics which I think everyone has
their own interesting story to tell
about where were you when this happened
but some of the conversations I had with
people on the campaign trail with voters
with the people who were in those crowds
the people who
I liked Trump I first had a sense that
Trump could win the nomination here in
Las Vegas I went to an event this is
still in the primary in 2015 here in Las
Vegas and Trump did a couple of things
that no other candidate does the
conventional wisdom among politicians is
that you want to keep an audience
waiting you know that you're not a
celebrity in your own right and suppose
Trump is but very few politicians are
and so they worked hard to create an air
of mystique around themselves they don't
want to be immediately accessible to
everybody especially if they're trying
to raise money it want to be a little
bit distant so people want to be closer
to this person so I was told by some
campaign consultants that one of the
things more seasoned candidates do is
they arrive on time but they wait in
some backroom for 15 or 20 minutes and
then they come onstage Trump didn't do
that at the event here in Las Vegas he
just came right out on time and he did
that throughout the campaign he was
almost always on time and the message
that sends to people in the audience who
have driven who have waited camped out
by the door or whatever the message that
sends is that their time is worth
something to him so there was an
immediate intimacy between the candidate
in the audience which most politicians
don't want they want a kind of adulation
they want a little bit of a distance
they want the audience to put them on a
pedestal Donald Trump came off the
pedestal and then he would stand there
for an hour and speak extemporaneously
about whatever was on his mind now when
the media started paying attention to
what he was saying once he had clinched
the nomination I remember the first
campaign speech they covered they were
saying this man's crazy this is a stream
of consciousness Rambo this has no
coherence that's what all of his
speeches were like but it wasn't crazy
if you were standing in the room it was
a conversation that you would have among
friends about current events and it was
an ordinary kind of conversation and
people appreciated that he was letting
them into his confidence sharing his
inner reflections with them the way he
still does on Twitter and in the New
York Times even some of these interviews
he gives he lets on a little bit too
much about what he's really thinking
about things but I don't think we've had
a president who's been as direct and as
accessible in terms of
letting people know his own mind he
doesn't let you know what his policies
are gonna be especially in foreign
policy that's a it's a mantra almost in
the trumpet's world we're not going to
tell you what we're gonna do with Isis
or with Iran or with Russia and I think
it's good to be unpredictable that's my
personal view and it's good to be
unpredictable for strategic reasons but
in terms of how he feels about things
he's very direct about that and that
created a rapport between him and his
audience and as I left that event that
night in 2015 I said there's no other
Republican candidate that does that no
one who can do it
Trump drew that night about 4,000 or
5,000 people to the West Gate casino I
think it was Marco Rubio had a rally a
few blocks away and he had about 200 and
and Rubio on paper in a sense was a
better candidate he had more political
experience his policies lined up
perfectly with conservative movement
Republican Party he was very good on
television he was Latino he could appeal
to a new section of the electorate
Republicans have been struggling to
reach so in a sense on paper he was the
guy who checked all the boxes but Trump
had this connection to people and it
wasn't just celebrity it was really
something he knew how to do it wasn't
demagoguery either it wasn't kind of a
charismatic persona you know when you
looked at Obama rally 'he's there was
almost that kind of charismatic pall
that fell over the crowd almost a cult
of personality people believed in and
they elevated him above them Trump had a
different appeal he was the man who
would come down from the Trump Tower on
the escalator sort of descending and and
giving up a lot of that prestige look
how his brands have suffered look how
his personal life has been
opened up and turned upside down how his
business is now under investigation he's
exposed himself in all of these ways for
the sake of this job and there was a
young woman on the campaign trail at a
rally in Michigan actually was one of
the more interesting rallies of the
campaign it was just north of Detroit
and it was one of the few events that
started late started late because we had
trouble getting there through some of
the traffic on the roads around Detroit
and the Secret Service were literally
clearing people off the roads because I
hadn't done it yet and it was very long
route anyway got there late
it was absolutely packed it was one of
the younger audiences you know
conservative audiences tend to be a
little bit older this was a young
audience people in their late teens
early 20s was like a rock and roll
concert and I asked one of the young
women near the media area what brought
her here and why she liked Donald Trump
and she said he loves us and I said to
her how do you know he loves you and she
said because he doesn't have to do this
and that was the same sentiment I'd seen
at the beginning of the campaign when I
first went to a Trump event that people
had an appreciation for the way that he
was giving his time that he was arriving
on time that he was giving up his
lucrative comfortable life to enter the
fray of American politics now you might
say it's not such a great sacrifice he
lives at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue it's
driven everywhere he's going to be
remembered in history his net worth is
probably risen as it does for all
presidents Obama is probably worth as
much as Mitt Romney at the moment which
is kind of ironic but the sense people
had was that he was sacrificing himself
for this it wasn't something that was
the next step up on a set of political
stairs the way it was for Hillary
Clinton and for other candidates
and I think that remains his connection
to his voting base that people feel that
he's giving something up for them and he
remains loyal to them and what's
remarkable in the first six months of
Trump's presidency is that despite the
daily ups and downs the roller coaster
ride that it's been through the media
and some of the setbacks in Congress and
so forth his own voters are almost
entirely 100 percent in lockstep still
with him and that's not because they
have a slavish cultish adherence to
Trump as a personality but it's because
he's delivering on things that he
promised them he would do it was very
interesting poll at the end of the first
hundred days that asked voters what they
thought about the Trump administration
and Democrats hated it Republicans loved
it but the one thing that both sides
agreed on was that he was doing what he
said he was going to do and Democrats
didn't like that he was doing what he
said he was going to do and Republicans
loved it but that was the one common
area of agreement and some of the polls
that came out around that time and I
think that's largely still true even
though he has met more obstacles
especially in Congress which I think was
unprepared for the trump presidency
hadn't really gotten all his ducks in a
row certainly I don't think that the
leaders of Congress expected Trump to
win I think some prepared for Trump to
win Mitch McConnell I think deserves a
lot of credit for the way he handled the
nomination of Merrick garland in 2016
and then Neal Gorsuch in 2017
he kind of held the line in the slim
chance that Trump was going to win and
he did so he made a big bet there but
mostly I think Washington was unprepared
so Trump is dealing with that he's
dealing with an extremely hostile media
he's dealing with a bureaucracy and an
administration that has portions of it
that are in not-so-secret rebellion
against his administration and I think
it's a massive challenge but so far he's
doing ok it's it's interesting to see
and certainly his voters feel that he's
delivering on what he promised them so
Pollak did you read Fear and Loathing in
Las Vegas before you know I didn't but
there's there's an element of Hunter s
Thompson in it although you know it's
not as crazy as that it's not it's not
as adventurous I talked a little bit in
the book about
some of the side trips I made while on
the campaign trail and one of the
interesting ones was to Harvard we
happen to be in New England and I flew
down from New Hampshire to Boston and I
joined some family friends there for the
Jewish Sabbath I observed the Jewish
Sabbath and I took that afternoon on
Saturday to walk across campus where I'd
studied and to visit some old friends
and one friend in particular who was a
quiet Trump supporter on campus there
were a few of them in the Harvard
faculty and we had this long long
discussion about Trump of what he meant
and especially about the perilous state
of American politics and American
political discourse and the thing that
worried us both at the time was that
whether Trump won or lost America was
going to be divided and it remains
divided remains bitterly divided and
it's not because of Trump it's not even
because of the campaign it goes back
earlier some of it starts in the Obama
administration some of it starts before
that but I remember almost with fondness
when I was in college in the 1990s the
big complaint among political
commentators were that the two parties
were too close to each other and that
American politics had become a kind of
consensus debate there was no real
disagreement there were no issues that
divided people that began to crack a
little bit with the impeachment and Bill
Clinton refusing to resign and then the
recount in 2000 so kind of looked back a
little a little ways to to see where
some of these divisions began but
certainly the Obama presidency was
divisive in that Obama
unlike Bill Clinton didn't react to
setbacks by coming toward the middle
whenever he had a political setback he
would move further in the direction he
had originally intended to go and I
think that for conservatives and
Republicans and many independents that
was frightening and so I think they
decided they needed someone to fight
back which was Trump's appeal in terms
of the style of his campaign
and here we are we have this agent of
change basically in the White House in a
way that Obama really wasn't Obama was
focused on changing the foundations of
society he spoke about the fundamental
transformation of the Constitution the
long arc of justice all this stuff
Obama was fixated on changing what he
saw as a society marred by the original
sin of slavery and racism and Trump
doesn't feel that way about America's
Founding he's trying to change America's
government and in a way that resonates
more deeply with the American electorate
which doesn't want to revisit its first
principles doesn't want to undo Liberty
doesn't want to apologize for the
American presence in the world but it
also causes a lot of problems in
Washington because government is set on
working a certain way and Trump wants it
to work differently Trump comes from the
real-estate world from a business world
where things are built where things are
done directly they're done early they're
done under budget Washington doesn't
work that way and there's this huge
clash of styles but the thing that
worried us in that little side trip I
took on the campaign trail remains
worrying to me now I wonder why we've
come as far down this road as we have
and one of the more interesting comments
in my book came from someone also a
Harvard professor who read it and and
told me that the thing he liked about my
book as someone from the outside was
that my personal account of being on the
campaign trail and following Trump made
Trump seemed normal to him because he is
not seen as normal in the media he's
either seen as you know terrible
dictatorial fascist whatever whatever
they apply to him or he's just seen as
this chimerical figure nobody can figure
out but when you are close to what's
going on and you can see the day-to-day
and you can place it in the broader
context of other people there at the
time and the geography and the changing
of the seasons whatever it is you
understand that there's an element of
this that is actually normal we've just
become used to a different way of doing
politics and maybe that's why people are
so frustrated with politics Trump is
trying to change that and some of those
changes are quite ambitious and maybe
challenging it sometimes
even radical but as a figure he's not
outside the bounds of the American
political experience and there's a lot
that's familiar about him if people
immerse themselves in this Trump world
with maybe some people don't want to do
but if if you don't want to go to a
trump rally and didn't want to do that
and get yourself inside the Trump's mind
to think about policy the way he does
you might want to read the book because
that's the part of the book I really
focused on was describing the world that
traveled with Trump and Larry Schweikart
his part of the book is really focused
on the historical context of Trump so he
really puts it in context how the Trump
campaign although different from
anything anyone has experienced
certainly in our lifetimes is not
totally unprecedented there are
presidents with this kind of campaign
for some of these kinds of ideas and
after giving the history because Larry's
a historian he also gives you the data
that further explained why Trump won and
how Trump won and by the way he's still
collecting some of that same data he
says that the shift from Democrat to
Republican in voter registration has
actually continued since the 2016
election that the momentum is still on
the Republican side even though if you
watch the news you might think it was
the opposite but the electorate is
following Trump on the issues and
Democrats aren't talking about issues
right now they're talking about Trump
and that's good at solidifying their
base it's good at bringing in donations
it's not good at broadening the
Democratic Party electorate and that's
why Democrats are still struggling to
figure out their strategies in the
midterms of 2018 that's why they're
almost paralyzed by this resistance
movement which they encourage but which
is so radical that Democratic Party
leaders are having trouble reigning it
in Trump's talking about the issues
people still care about trade national
security health care and
that's why the electric continues to
trend in this direction we'll see how
much longer that lasts but if you can
start delivering on more of these things
particularly on the legislative side
then I think you'll see that trend
accelerated in how Trump won you talk
about as you said your experiences on
the campaign trail what was it
what's it like to be on the campaign
trail and what was the reaction you got
from the other reporters being a part of
bright bucks yeah well like Breitbart
fights with the media a lot so when I
joined the press playing I knew I wasn't
gonna make too many friends I was
surprised that I did make some friends
but I knew not to try to be too
colloquial with people because either
they wouldn't want that kind of
relationship with a Breitbart reporter
or maybe I wouldn't you know I had to
keep focused on on what I often felt
people weren't focusing on you know the
interesting thing to me was how few
journalists took an interest in the
crowds there was a kind of condescension
fear and irritation not every reporter
and not all the time but I found many
reporters stayed within the media pen
the sort of page they they put you in at
these big events and I would just jump
the fence I mean you know Secret Service
was there but you know I didn't really
care I was going to talk to people that
to me that was that's what made the news
story was talking to people at these
rallies and it struck me that there
wasn't that much curiosity about Trump
supporters that the media had an idea
already baked in about what Trump
supporters were I'm generalizing there
again not everybody was like that but
it was fun I mean there were some
friendships made across ideological
boundaries there were some very
left-wing reporters I got along very
well with because we talked about
baseball the Cubs were in the World
Series at the time I wore my Cubs hat
everywhere as a royal Cubs fan and it
was fun just to be on the trail many of
the reporters didn't like Trump but most
of them would agree and some some quite
open about it
that it was better to be covering Trump
than covering Hillary Clinton because
Hillary Clinton did very few events and
there wasn't much access to the
candidate and there was not much change
from day to day the speeches were
scripted that the crowds were bused in
and it was all the setup set pieces of
politics that you're used to
Trump was different you never knew what
was going to happen you never knew which
protester was going to show up there
were four or five events a day he was
going all over the place
it was absolutely exhausting